hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in chapter 6 of his categories Aristotle
is now going to treat what we're
translating as quantity the Greek for
that is topo sown and this can be used
in an interrogative way to ask well how
much or how many or how long all these
sort of quantitative terms quantitative
concepts that we have of things this is
the first of the categories after
substance that Aristotle will treat and
we have to be a little bit careful not
to equate it immediately with everything
that we associate with the quantitative
because as we're going to see Aristotle
is going to say no no some of that
actually is a matter of relation the
Proust team there's there's some other
respects in which we we want to keep
this clear but we'll see that as we go
through the chapter so what is quantity
when we're predicating something in the
category of quantity we are saying how
much or how long or some other you know
number related term of it and Aristotle
will start at the beginning by talking
about some of these being discreet
some of these being continuous so that's
an important way to separate some of
these these types of quantity or ways in
which we use quantity out one of these
on the discrete side and we'll see why
it's discrete in just a little while is
number itself or wreaths most and in
Greek the word that we get arithmetic
from right literally the learning of
numbers but then he also says speech and
here he uses the term logos which can
mean a lot of different things but then
he clarifies later on that what he's
talking about is the logos that is
associated with phone a phone a is is
coming from the word speaking and so it
has to do with the kind of logos that
hit that has to do with speech talking
right and why would he talk about speech
itself as as being quantitative these
well you'd do a word count or something
like that he doesn't actually have that
in mind what he has in mind is something
that were not really used to thinking
about but we could import into our own
language in ancient Greek and also in
ancient Latin poetry words were class or
syllables of words were classified as
long or short and you could have a meter
based on the lengths of syllables as a
matter of fact what made things poetic
was not rhyming at the end as it is in
English or in French or things like that
but in particular the metre that still
has some effect in English in French and
other poetry but for the for the ancient
Greeks that was really what made it
poetic so you know when you hear about I
am big pin diameter those sorts of
things the meter that's being talked
about there that's that's part of the
number and why
is this discreet well we're gonna get to
that but it but a very short you know
forecastle well each syllable is its own
thing each syllable is independent of
the other sort of like numbers are
independent of each other then we have
quantity in another sense where it's
continuous and Aristotle will talk about
continuous quantity as having some sort
of connection between the parts there is
a limit that that divides them apart
from each other so for example he talks
about a line right he says here we
discover that limit of which we have now
just been speaking there's no limit
between the syllables but there is
between parts of a line what is the
limit the point on the line so it is
with a plane right a plane is a
two-dimensional figure composed of lines
the line is the limit between them so
with a solid or a body right a soul MA
you know we can talk then about planes
and so Aristotle is using some some
ideas from geometry here to talk about
continuous quantity he says their parts
have a limit a line in the case of the
the plane a line or plane in the in the
case of the body and then he also
suggests we can think about time and
space as being continuous quantity as
well
he's going to backpedal a little bit on
time and we're going to talk about this
as a separate topic in a different video
but space is certainly continuous in in
this respect much the way that you know
solids are if we imagine and this is not
I'm not suggesting that we do this but
and hold that this is an adequate you
know physical representation of all
space but we can think of space as a
three-dimensional solid if we like just
one that things can move around it or
you know if you're like a
three-dimensional void right its parts
are continuous with each other so two
different way
of thinking about quantity discretes
each of the parts are separate from each
other
or they don't necessarily imply each
other in the way that they do with with
continuous so let's let's go back and
look very quickly at you know what he
says about number it says consider the
parts of a number you'll find there's no
common limit at which they join or unite
so two fives make 10 but these two 5s
are wholly distinct from each other
there's no common limit there's no like
you know a little joining place between
the two fives although perhaps we might
picture that to ourselves in our head
when we're first learning arithmetic
right we're putting blocks together
something like that then it's actually
physical objects that we're putting
together to represent the numbers that
are really the main issue there right
sorry says there's no common limit the
same would be the you know with the
parts three and seven in the case of all
numbers you will never find such a
boundary common to any two parts for the
parts remain ever distinct from each
other and he says this also about speech
meaning these syllables now you know
this goes against a good bit of what we
now know from modern linguistics so you
probably would want to put this aside
when we talk about that we're thinking
less in terms of like the length of
syllables and more in terms of the
phonemes that we we are using but that's
sort of a separate topic in any case you
should be able to see the distinction
here that he's making now another really
along with that of course quantities are
made up of parts that is in part how we
can number them or or measure them or
say it's this much or that much or
anything along those those lines so that
is one really important way of
characterizing what it is for something
to be predicated
in the category of quantity I put over
here something that comes up towards the
end of the chapter but I think is very
helpful for understanding the other
stuff that Aristotle discusses at you
know considerable length characteristic
Leone in the Greek the thing that's
specific to quantity is that it deals
with equality so East Zone and
inequality to Anees so Aristotle is
going to specify that this does not mean
likeness like two things being similar
in that they are both white like these
pieces of chalk right where I suppose
there might be no there's no blue that
correspond to the blue of this shirt but
just imagine that there was then then we
would have likeness equality is
something a bit of a stronger relation
and Aristotle is saying that what we're
predicating has to do with things being
equal or unequal and not a number of
other things that we do tend to
associate with number and which they did
also in Aristotle's time he brings this
up in terms of contraries so contraries
are things like you know black white
good bad hot cold you know also to a
certain extent true and false are
contrary to each other although that's
that's a little bit complex and
Aristotle is going to say well let's
consider the the sorts of things that
somebody might say quantities don't have
contraries all right
why not so he he says there we go this
will be perfectly clear in the case of
all definite quantities whereby I mean
for example two cubits or three cubits
long or a surface or something of that
sort these he says have no contrary
three doesn't have a con
Prairie in at least the mathematics as
Aristotle is considering and or in terms
of quantity itself right now we might
say well what about negative numbers we
have negative three and okay that's a
possible valid objection but it's not
something that Aristotle is considering
at the time perhaps if we do want to
think along those lines we would say
well that's not quite the sort of
contrariness that he has in mind so he
says but somebody might say reasonable
objection here what about great and
small polu and Olli gong those could
also be translated as many and few right
or much and little mega and me Crone I
could also say big and little right
aren't those contraries so here's where
Aristotle says a few interesting things
that we want to keep distinct from each
other one is that these are not actually
contraries in a proper sense so he says
these are more properly regarded as
terms of relation as such things are not
great or small you can say that
something is great or small in relation
to something else right so for example
my body I'm a big guy I'm like six foot
three right so that makes me fairly big
among among human beings does that make
me big among mammals in general no
because we have elephants and you know
hippopotami and blue whales and things
along those lines right I'm pretty small
in comparison to those so a greatness
and smallness are not something that's
in me irrespective of a context the way
that for example we could say heat or
cold or goodness or badness or these
other things that we consider to be
contrary are right so he says you know
for example uh you know
a person can be sick or healthy a thing
black and white
neither can can anything be at the same
time thus qualified but we can say that
something is both great and small at the
same time or that it's many and also few
at the same time so these are not really
contrary to begin with and you say well
give that that's that's fine so that
shows that number doesn't have contries
but number at least does have these
right you can be great or small or much
or or little this is where it gets very
interesting so he says these are not the
sorts of things that actually apply to
number why not because they are
relational terms and they're not really
quantity they are terms that are using
something like quantity in the way that
they're describing the relation but
they're not quantity itself we come back
to this this thing and number is what it
is and other numbers are not equal to it
and the fact that they could be greater
or lesser that's a relation between them
so that's important you'll also go on
and discuss another very similar concept
we could say the more and the less the
Malone and hate shown and you know we
can talk for example about whiteness
right this truck is whiter than this
paper is hopefully you can see this and
although we described my face as white
my face is not really white either in
comparison to those so any whiteness
that it is this much less white it's
less and something else is is more and
he says that quantities don't have this
now that's a very paradoxical thing to
say isn't it that quantities do not have
a greater and a lesser
so he says think about two cubits long
this does not admit of gradations a
thing is not two cubits long in a
greater degree than another and they
says the same thing holds of numbers 1 3
is not so to speak 3 in a greater degree
than another another 1/5 is not 5 in a
greater degree than another and he says
one period of time as well
is not more time than another and he
says nor of any other quantity can a
more or less be affirmed so the category
of quantity does not admit degrees
instead what it admits of is this these
these equality and inequality and then
if you like you know something like
sequence so we can say that 3 is a you
know larger number than 2 like when
we're counting we count 3 after we count
2 and here Aristotle is actually
anticipating some interesting things
that will come up in number theory much
later on and I think about how we
actually define number Aristotle
considers number to be sort of the
paradigmatic example of quantity but
it's it's a one type of quantity so
hopefully this is a useful introduction
to this whole category of quantity